avec des ceintures multicolores plein
les yeux 1500 jeunes judoka de la région
participait à un entraînement
exceptionnel aujourd'hui leur prof d'un
jour et bien ce sont les membres de
l'équipe de France de judo c'était au
parc des expositions de Tours dans le
cadre de la tournée des champions 24
étapes chaque année dans toute la France
pour faire découvrir et partager
l'esprit judo Faustine Ludo s'est rendu
sur place merci à vous
épinez mais impatient juste avant la
rencontre l'excitation et palpable parmi
les jeunes judokas impressionnés de voir
leurs idoles on représente notre petit
club face à ces grands du judo donc
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'énorme
pour moi si Teddy Riner était là alors
là je serai aux anges
ont eu des titres quand même pas mal je
pense je vais faire une photo avec eux
mais je vais essayer ouais de demander
leur parcours un peu comment ils ont
évolué savoir à peu près où ils étaient
tous de nombreux clubs d'Indre-et-Loire
ont répondu présent pour les professeurs
de judo l'opportunité était trop belle
pour la manquer ils ont tous la télé
maintenant quand même même à truie vous
savez on est un petit peu en campagne
mais là vous voir les champions en chair
et en hausse pour aller toucher pourra
discuter avec eux surtout qu'ils vont
tout faire pour pour être auprès d'eux
ça va être un souvenir j'espère
merveilleux
Alexandre
Frédéric Lecanu Alexandre Idir ou encore
Amandine Buchard leur nom font rêver
entre exercices et démonstration les
champions prodiguent leurs conseils et
parlent de leur parcours
aux enfants moi aussi j'étais ceinture
blanche aussi j'ai fait les petits
compétitions de quartier jusqu'à
atteindre un certain niveau et j'ai fait
partie de ses enfants qui ont participé
à l'itinéraire des champions au mercredi
équipe de France qu'on avait avant et
moi ils m'ont juste fait rêver et c'est
vrai que bah ce qui m'ont procuré
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de le rendre de
leur transmettre en réalisant cette
tournée l'équipe de France veut
encourager la pratique de ce sport de
combat et plus encore c'est aussi la
volonté de développer les valeurs du
judo on est assis sur une mine d'or le
judo ce sont des des valeurs
fondamentales ce sont des moments
d'exception qu'on peut vivre grâce à
cette discipline des moments qui vont se
reproduire puisque la tournée n'est pas
terminée l'équipe fera escale dans la
Drôme et l'Ardèche dans une dizaine de
jours